hold on how many how many episodes did I
miss
um so if you were like you went to
Europe and you're all over the place no
you I don't think I missed that many you
you had a couple this year two yeah
no it was just that period where your
Visa was all [ __ ] so you left and
you're like whoa
bounce out to Europe for a little bit
and so there was like that weird
three-week period
where I did like one episode with Marcus
and then oh yeah one with Sam and Spock
yeah and there was like oh yeah yeah yep
yeah so so long ago keep talking because
I'm gonna pull up I'm gonna pull up our
YouTube and scroll back I did this
yesterday and actually I was so nice
um back then I was just so precious I
mean I still am but I was so precious
about
the sh like the show success and I was
just so scared of like
dude at least one of us has to be here
people are gonna be [ __ ] pissed like
yeah I mean especially because of
patreon and also like having that those
right when we rented the bigger Studio
yeah and so all of a sudden we had then
more rent to pay and that was scary yeah
it was like if people aren't on patreon
aren't happy then that money's gonna go
away and then we have to just you know
that's another lease on top of this
apartment
I just collect leases I mean isn't that
just life yeah kind of you're trying to
collect a car lease yeah a house lease
you know
um a four-wheeler lease
you want to be in as much of that as
possible yeah that's the American way
yeah damn these episodes okay so yeah so
we'll start at the beginning here right
and this this is actually great because
um I have such a like a blurred memory
like when we were talking about the Miss
bonus episodes yesterday and you were
like no no it's like we didn't do one I
I totally forgot that we only did the
monthly for a long time yeah I forgot
all that [ __ ] yeah at the beginning the
way we started our patreon was the
people on patreon got the episode a week
early and then once a month we would do
a bonus episode so like a lot of these
we're at the table this table and then
we would go to your apartment and set up
those two metal chairs
and do them from there I didn't realize
we started using my apartment so early
for some reason I remembered the first
like
10 episodes being in your apartment
because two of those at least were
insanely chill and the one with yes
Victor Victor oh yeah and we did one
with Marcus yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
we did a lot more
at this table and then we switched to
your apartment and then actually way
sooner than I thought we got that first
the studio yo that studio what a time
yeah we needed that that was extreme
podcasting it really was trying to get
there before the dude next to us who was
definitely living in his Studio
would like wake and bake and start
making beats yeah all of a sudden like
mid record we just hear that deep
booming of a subwoofer yeah you know
like you're in a movie theater and you
hear the theater next to you go look
like they're watching like you know
Marvel movie or something like that and
something crazy happens it sounded like
that and we were like mid recording we'd
be like no and all of a sudden he would
just start playing this crazy beat and
then weed smoke would just start wafting
through the vent
no
foreign
and then we get subtle contact
that's probably why we were funnier than
yeah we'd always start the episode by
chatting about politics and intellectual
stuff yeah and it would just end up at
the end of us being like
[Laughter]
two dicks
this all seems like it was
so much longer ago uh-huh like it feels
like we've been in Candace now for way
longer than we have been like years and
years
that was my main takeaway from like like
going back to this YouTube page is that
like the time like it was just way
sooner than I thought like we've done a
[ __ ] ton in just five years yeah five
years seems like a lot of time but then
when you scroll back through this it's
like this feels like it was yesterday
but also feels like it was way further
away I'm not making sense but I feel
like that's how memory works you know
yeah far and close but what's also cool
about
going back through this is is seeing
like how much
we learned about production along the
way and just like what it takes to
I don't know like we were learning about
business
everything yeah yeah along the way like
just making sure we're balancing how
much we were making with how much we
were spending on the and I think we were
a little bit more frugal than we
probably needed to be but like yeah you
know what this what it ends up being is
us like slowly
gearing up and and you just like see the
kind of the chapters
yeah I remember people some people
actually being
almost mad at us because we're obviously
doing well
but they're like here's in this piece of
[ __ ] Studio why do you need all that
money
but I think
what was good was we were just kind of
because we never spent it like at a
point very early you were like all right
let's not spend any of this like let's
save it and then see what we can do I
think because we did that
like being Frugal in the beginning
enabled us to really kind of experiment
like when we invested in this set at the
nuclear fallout Center yeah and we
really flipped it around that felt
really cool because we had the cash to
do it and we were like oh we can kind of
go all out yeah and then we got Candace
even more so we were like sitting on a
you know like a business that was like
really working and we're like okay now
we can maximize the creative as well
yeah I think other people in our
position
may have just taken that money and
bought stupid [ __ ] for themselves or
they would have attempted what we
attempted like way later way too early
and just [ __ ] it all up yeah
so I think we also had to like for the
first tour it's like the the casa that
came out of our own that yeah there's a
lot of initial upfront investment yeah
for like a tour bus for example that you
have to like write a check for before
you actually start making money from the
shows yeah I think that's something that
we didn't even I don't even think we
really made that clear at the time
um
and that's actually probably an
interesting thing to talk about was when
we did our very first tour we were given
two offers
there was a company that was going to
give us like a flat fee and they were
going to kind of
essentially essentially invest in the
tour and then they would have made money
like if we sold out they would have made
a bunch of money off of us and we just
would have kind of taken the flat fee
and the gamble was that they would
invest in like the tour bus and the crew
cost and the production cost
um you know moving the merch around
whatever and we wouldn't have to pay any
of that and so we gambled on that
by essentially betting on ourselves
every tour but yeah like like you said
we had a lot of those initial upfront
costs and we were able to cover those to
kind of like be in control of our career
which most other people
you know
they like
because we had the option to not get
bankrolled by someone else that was
great because I think in entertainment
you're often at the mercy of other
people so to be in control of what we're
doing I think was pretty special in and
of itself yeah so anyways
um it's just cool to look back you know
now that this podcast is five years old
to look back at all the different
I don't know sets and just yeah like
Seasons we went through and it's just
crazy you know and it just it's just
cool so
thank you to you all for supporting us
this long yes thank you so much for
watching and uh if you used to watch or
you still watch
we appreciate you and uh it's been a
wild ride
um and thanks to the staff too now
you're now that you're all fired I mean
we can kind of be yeah you know honest
and a little bit
um I felt with you guys just want to
thank you guys yeah so much
um it always comes full circle and it
seems like the circle
comes back to the apartment exactly with
zero staff